sous forme de joutes oratoires ou plus
au calme en défendant son discours
individuellement ils étaient une
trentaine de collégiens argumenté sur
les réseaux sociaux initié par le
département des yvelines ce concours
d'éloquence avait de multiples objectifs
je trouve que c'est très important
d'abord ils vont avoir besoin dans le
cadre de leur examen et puis dans
plus tard même dans leurs études moi
j'ai trouvé en tout cas ce que j'ai pu
voir aujourd'hui des prestations
extraordinaires des jeunes de 3e à voir
je dirais une une éloquence comme celle
ci une aisance sur le plateau face alors
à leurs camarades et on voit qu'il ya un
travail de fond je crois que c'est
fondamental aujourd'hui de redonner la
place à la parole à l'expression et à la
confiance en soi et l estime de soi
aussi de type d'exercice était proposé
un argumentaire et un duel et les élèves
étaient évalués par un jury composé de
trois personnes une journaliste une
avocate est un artiste c'est intéressant
parce qu'il se confronte à
l'argumentation à comment poser son avis
on voit aussi qu'ils sont dans la
confrontation de l'ecoute cercle comment
on s'écoute et que mon écoute les
arguments des uns des autres alors quand
on sait en solo c'est plus simple quand
c'est en duo c'est plus compliqué alors
on a une effectivement une grille de
notation
ensuite on évalue justement les ans le
font les postures l'interaction avec le
public puisque tout ça en fait forme un
tout autre but développer sa confiance
en soi pas facile devant une salle
comble de 400 collégiens au début
j'étais un peu stressé je vous avoue
tout mais au fil du temps dès que tu es
arrivé sur scène et que j'ai commencé à
parler je trouve que je trouvais que ça
allait bien j'avais un peu le public
avec moi je sais pas si c'est vrai mais
voilà ça m'a donné de la confiance même
si j'ai pas réussi à placer tous mes
arguments mon adversaire était très bon
il faut l'avouer j'étais jeune c'était
pas mon objectif de base de gagné et
j'étais très fier de moi c'est
impressionnant c'est à profac janzéens
et
et non très bonne ambiance ce qui ce qui
nous ont aidés pendant six mois étaient
géniaux une bonne mentalité dans ce
terreau monde hyper enrichissant plus
trois trophées ont été remis à l'issue
du concours le trophée du meilleur
éloquent pour l'argumentaire le trophée
du meilleur éloquent pour le duel est un
dernier trophée pour l'établissement qui
a comptabilisé le plus de points tout au
long du concours